it's my great pleasure to introduce
albert at sirius
uh albert is a professor at upc
barcelona he probably doesn't need any
introduction but i think
i will give one anyway he's a legend in
complexity theory
for many reasons he has two phd's one in
proof complexity and another in finite
model theory
i believe i got that right and in
addition he has
done excellent work in
proof complexity descriptive complexity
finite model theory and
and building bridges between these areas
of complexity theory and logic
and he has won many many awards for his
work
and today uh albert is going to talk
about
the past and present of descriptive
complexity theory so his take on
on the whole field so without further
ado albert the floor is yours
please thank you very much vijay for the
introduction
and thank you everybody for joining so
indeed i'm going to talk about past and
present of descriptive complexity theory
initially the title had fitter but i
cannot predict the filter so i removed
that from the title
and many of the things that i'm going to
talk about are survey
and they don't include results of my own
in fact many of the things go back to
before the time i was born like for
example the turing machine
so my thesis in this talk is that
descriptive complexity is really one way
to see it is
by looking at the model of computation
in which we're doing
our algorithms so let's remind ourselves
what the turing machine is so the turing
machine works at the
beat level so it has the tape where you
have some
cell that is the current cell and then
the control has a set of instructions
and instructions that they do
the usual thing they read a symbol and
then they
do three things depending on what the
symbol is they rewrite the symbol with
another one
they move the head left or right and
they jump to another instruction in the
instruction set now crucially the set of
instructions is a finite
set so this is a finite machine
and it's operating at the bit level and
for that reason many
typically mathematicians tend to think
that this is not a natural model because
it
it doesn't have a sufficient structure
to be able to analyze it
mathematically so but
in fact it's not the only model of
computation that works at the big level
there is a
very closely related model in fact which
is the boolean circuit
and this is what shannon in fact very
early in 1938 this was his master thesis
in mit he called relay and switching
circuits
and this is a remarkable paper where he
was
talking about boolean circuits and
essentially the way we
we think of them today so have some
inputs that take
boolean values x1 to x5 in this example
and then you have some gates where you
do some obvious computation it takes two
inputs and produces another
another bit as an output and
so one way to represent this computation
here is by the set of equations that you
see on the right
so every gate gets a variable and then
you express what is the
effect of the gate on its image
and sharon himself analyzed the circuits
this way
and what this is what we call in the
satisfiability
uh literature we call it satan
transformation but maybe it should be
called the shannon transformation
because this
challenge used this to actually reason
about the correctness and about
uh issues about the about the circuit
exactly using boolean logic this way
all right so so these are two models of
competition they are extremely
they are very well connected one with
the other there are transformations
and from one to the other but
the the thing is that both are bit based
they are based on
working with bits and we now know and we
also already knew back in the 30s but
at the time i mean the notion of uh
encodings was actually quite new and
this was one of the contributions of
goddamn that things can be encoded at
the bit level
right but uh we know that
the data has structure it's not data is
not just a
bunch of bits so data comes from
something that we
want to understand and analyze such as
graphs it could be directed graphs or
undirected graphs it could be weighted
could have hyper graphs where edges have
more than more one verb and two vertices
you could have a graph that have
structure of the three
partially ordered sets even casey net
formulas you can think of
as them as structured data so in this
example we have the clauses on the left
in this case three clauses and the
variables on the right you have a
bipartite graph
with two types of edges which denote
occurrence
and the occurrence of red could mean for
example that variable x1
appears in the closed in negative
polarity and green would mean that it
appears with positive variety
so even though kcnf formulas are quite
low-level
representation of of data they are still
more structured than just plain bit
strings other type of data which
we might want to manipulate our matrices
which also have some structure and we'll
get back to it
later again so if data has structure
then um why do we break the structure
completely and we turn it into bit
strings and
that that is actually a problem and this
was a problem that
at the beginning of database theory and
code realized that there was this
problem of how
databases are represented and he
introduced the model of relational model
of data the
relational databases and this was as
early as 1970
and the model is the following so it
clarified
it but it was a very
clean way of representing data comparing
to what was at the time
this was still before the time i was
born
so i'm just reading from from the papers
so what is the relational model in the
relational model we have some relations
and this is your input and what are
relations
well these are just sets of tuples where
a tuple is uh
um a bunch of elements from different
domains
and these domains decide uh tell what is
the type of this relation this is how
it's called
so here is an example on the right you
have a bipartite graph you have two
types of vertices vertices
from some string domain and
vertices from some numeric domain and
then you have some relation between them
and that relation is the edge relation
in the bipartite graph
so in this example the three the three
relations would be
the set of vertices u the set of
vertices v
and the relation of h e itself
okay so so cod said
let's represent databases this way in
with relations and in fact he
he acknowledges that this goes back to
tarski
when he has this algebra of relations
and he introduces the concept of
relational algebra
and crediting for it so he says
okay what can we do with these relations
we can manipulate them somehow
some ways right so we can do
intersection of two relations provided
they are of the same type
we can do union of relations provided
they are of the same type you can do set
difference
we can do cartesian products what now
the types concatenate
and then there are two special
operations one is the selection
operation this is
denoted by sigma i and j and what this
represents are the tuples in the
relation
t where i and j component are equal this
is the equal selection
and then we have projections where in
projections we have again one component
and what you do is that you remove the
element in that component
so you take all the tuples in t and you
remove that component so
we say that we project i out of the
relation
so these are the operations the basic
operations of the relational algebra
and code suggested that with databases
represented in his relational
model data should be manipulated with
this
sort of operation so
now we can formulate what code himself
called relational algebra expressions so
this is again like
some sort of a circuit it's written this
way to
to show the analogy so now the inputs
are not bits but they are relations
themselves so the whole relation is put
as an input and
how you have the basic operations inside
so these are expressions
in this algebra of relations
and again you can do the intermediate
relations and
and then you can measure the complexity
of the expression by
how wide these relations are how
how many cartesian products we do in
this sort of analysis that we could do
good so these are relational algebra
expressions
and then um so code related this to
something quite familiar which is the
the first order logic on on
on a relational language so he noticed
and he proved that relational algebra
can compete precisely the same relations
from
from given relations it can compute the
same relations that you can
define with first of the logic
intersection corresponds to conjunction
union corresponds to disjunction
difference corresponds to medications
and this sigma this selection is the
equality relation which we usually
assume given for free
and the projection is precisely the
existential quantification
where now these variables range over the
domains of
our data model
by the way once you have negation and
existence of quantification you also
have
universal quantification one thing to
notice is that
relational algebra is variable free
there are no variables
the uh there are no individual variables
so what you're operating with these
relations directly
in particular you're not doing any
choices so when
when you do an intersection you apply
the intersection to
both relations to every sample in the
relation
and when you do a projection you apply
the projection to every tuple in the
relation
you're not working individually with
elements or tuples of your structure
and this is important because
choice-free computation
is what we're after in domains like
databases and
in other places and that's a bit my
point here so
so before i go to to what descriptive
complexity brought
into the picture of complexity theory so
let me make a one comment which is the
comment
between uniformity and non-uniformity
one thing to notice in the difference
between boolean circuits
and relational algebra expressions is
that a single
expression or single formula
can serve all inputs of a given type so
here is an example
if you want to define for a given graph
this the vertices or the set of vertices
that belong to a triangle
then you have this single formula this
is a finite object with
uh 25 symbols or something where you're
saying
x is in the relation that you're trying
to define if there are two vertices that
form a triangle one of which is x
yes so that's the first order formula
and this single first order formula of
finite set of symbols
serves all input graphs and these input
graphs are now
our input relations so in this sense
it's a uniform model
but we could also imagine that we have a
non-uniform computation where we could
have for example a different relational
algebra expression for
different input lengths this is an
approach that is actually quite useful
but it's not the one i'm following in
this and it's not the one
traditionally followed in descriptive
complexity so and
because of today i want to focus on past
and presence of descriptive complexity
we are we're
going to focus on the uniform these
things are usually called queries so
this is a query on graphs
they are graphs because the types are
vertices and edges
very good so uniformity versus one
uniformity
and now comes the issue of computability
with relations we have the
model of data and now we want to say how
do we compute with installations well we
already discussed the architectural
algebra
but is it uh powerful enough is this
model powerful enough
well ahoy mormon uh discussed this
and among many others actually around
the late 70s and
early 80s this was an issue of
discussion
but i think this quote here is uh
pertinent given
woman's recent touring award so i think
let's see what um said the general
consensus
about the model of computation for
relations
is that one does not wish to have
general turing machine capabilities
so that's a bit funny thing to say uh or
you don't want to
to be too incomplete so but there are
reasons for that and they go ahead
and discuss the reasons for it and the
reasons is these principles that they
formulate that they say that
and we want this computation to be order
independent for example that's one thing
we want and what does that mean is that
well the way the relation is presented
to you the order in which the tuples are
presented
to the machine should not affect the
output of the computation
and that's important for databases for
because you want
representation independence of your
queries
you want your queries to depend only on
the truly structural data not on the
representation of the data
the second principle which is typically
quite related and it's a bit hard to
distinguish one from the other but
there is a bit of a difference is the
isomorphism in variance
so here what uh what they mean here is
that if you rename the elements
then the output should only change up to
the
same renaming in particular and this is
an important point
if a structure if an input has a certain
automorphism
if you couldn't meaning that you can
exchange two elements in your structure
and not notice the difference then the
output
should also have this automorphism so
this is
an important concept for for preserving
the abstraction that is already in the
input
and you want to preserve you want this
relational structure
okay so this model of computation
introduced or these principles
of the model of computation introduced
in the 70s
um was the guiding principle for
for for databases but then complexity
theory also had something to say here
and so fagin's theorem in fact is
earlier
and effective steering the way it can be
interpreted is as a way to say that
the isomorphic invariant of the
iso-invariant
fragment of np coincides precisely with
existential second order logic
so what is uh what is existential
converter logic well you take
a first order formula where you have
some input relations and some
auxiliary relations that are quantified
existentially and this is
existential second order because this is
first order and this is a second order
relation
and it's existential because you don't
quantify universally over second order
relations
so faking theorem is exactly this
statement that i wrote here
and what makes it an interesting
statement is that
the thing on the left is really a
semantic class
if you think of it as just by itself
because the fact that the
non-deterministic polynomial time
machine
computes an isomorphism in variant
property is not even a decidable
condition
and this is not something you can impose
on the machine by just
putting a clock for example the fact
that the machine runs in polynomial time
is not a decidable condition either
but you can enforce it by just putting a
clock
but here isomorphism invariant is not
something you can enforce by
such a simple device but in fact you do
you can enforce it because this is
class of existential second order logic
is a syntactic class it's a syntactic
meaning that the set of formulas
that you are allowed to use are clearly
the sizable set so
so your devices are the same
okay so this is characterizing a
semantic class in terms of a syntactic
class and that's what makes it
interesting
in one direction the reason it works is
that you have the power to guess
these existential quantifiers and the
other direction
from from machines to existential second
order project in fact
is nothing else than cook's theorem done
in
sufficiently abstract way so that you
preserve the automotives
good so this is fake instead it's
already covered
so let's move on so
here's the rule nobody likes zeus i
think
or for a few people like zeus but i
think zeus
at least have a good thing it's that
at least they are not jungles right i
mean they are organized so
so here is what we call logics zoo in
the same way that there is the
complexity class
so so let me give you a map of how to
write this
so down here we have complexity classes
from the complexities
and up here we have a bunch of logics
that correspond more or less to these
classes so for example
here in this cage this green
cage here we have np which is completely
characterized by existential second
order logic
and in fact this characterization can
also be done for the polynomial
hierarchy where you go to
full second order logic and you could
even do it for b space and exponential
time
by looking at proper uh that's certain
extension of second order logic
albert yes can i ask a very naive
question
yes when you say that existential second
order logic is the same thing as
np like np deals with languages and
whether strings are in languages so what
are our strings in our languages is it
like whether a structure somehow
satisfies a sentence or how should i
think about this yeah good good question
thank you
so by this what i mean is the language
encoding the relation so the inputs are
really relations but they are somehow
encoded
and now what i want to say is that uh a
language
so a collection of structures meaning of
relations
is accepted by your machine if the
encoding is accepted by
a certain machine okay so it's the
encoding itself
but what you want is that this machine
is isomorphic environment
meaning that two
encodings of the same structure after
isomorphism should be accepted
both or rejected
so really the thing goes through
encodings
and potential b as bit strings but what
you wanted
is that these encodings are either if
two encodings represent the same
structure up to isomorphism then either
both are accepted or both are rejected
okay but i can think of this as like my
favorite np complete
graph problem what fagin says that there
is
like an as logical sentence exists
x and then some phi which sort of nails
down exactly the graphs that
have this property that make them yes
instances
absolutely yes okay yes thank you so
much
thanks
all right so here's my zoo again and so
let me
give you this thing so we have first of
the logic down here in existential
second order
here and we have um um
okay so this question marks what do i
mean here well i have question marks
because we don't know of a logic that
corresponds exactly twice above is an
invariant polynomial in the same way
that we know
our logic that corresponds to
isomorphism invariant then b
we don't know one for polynomial time we
don't know one for non-nondeterministic
log space
so it seems to be that there is a
dividing line between p and np
into the possibility or at least as far
as we know today
of uh capturing precisely the
isomorphism in varying fractions
of that complexity class for polynomial
time it's the
most attempt so i did this cage quite
long because i wanted to show the fact
that there
have been several attempts and the
arrows that have a cross means that it's
been proved that
they are not equivalent and the arrows
that don't have a cross mean that
they are just simulations there are two
logics that are
particularly important the fixed point
logic and physical logic with calc
so fixed point logic with counting is
the focus that i want to give here it's
quite close to polynomial time in a
quite
clear sense and well understood so let's
let's get into that
all right so what is the fixed point
logic first before i define fpc i need
to define fb
so fp stands for inflationary fixed
point logic usually
some people put an i in front
inflationary fixed point
or fixed point just for short what do we
have in this logic
we have the usual things we have inputs
we have equalities
quantification over elements in the
domains
boolean connectives and then we have an
inflationary fixed point
operator what is that well that's
nothing else than iteration
that's what i wrote here on the left so
i have the usual things input selection
projection
boolean combination and iteration so
what does it mean to iterate
well it's this very simple pseudocode
you start with the empty relation
and now you form the relation of tuples
that satisfy
psi given the current relation in this
case the empty set
and then while the new relation is not
equal to the old relation then you
iterate
you update the new relation and then you
update the new thing to be
what you had before plus the new tuples
that are satisfied
that satisfied psi so this way you get
new tuples
and you iterate until this converges
into some fixed point
and that that's what you operate now one
thing to notice is that because it's
inflationary because each time we are
adding new tuples
this is going to be this is going to
converge
yes and in fact it converges in time
which is polynomial
in the arity of the relation symbol r
in this case or x in this case
sorry a polynomial in the size of the
input with exponent that is the additive
of this relation because there are no
more
elements to be added than that number
and now comes the immerman party theorem
what you may have heard
which is essentially saying that the
term deterministic polynomial time can
be captured by inflationary fixed point
logic except that there is a big if and
the big if
is that it requires the domains to be
ordered and to allow
this order on the relations on the on
the
on the domain elements so once you have
this if
then this is no longer a semantic class
because isomorphism invariance becomes
trivial because
if the domain is fixed by an order then
there is nothing you can
you can permit within the same structure
other than just changing the names
so the automorphisms become trivial and
therefore it's no longer a semantic
class
still this is a powerful tool and in
fact we're going to see an application
of it
but it's not solving the question of
whether there is a logic for isomorphic
invariant p
so the question that we want to ask is
why do we insist people ask why do we
insist on order domains why is that so
important well for one thing fake
institution doesn't need this
right while p seems to require it at
least as far as we know
today and therefore there seems to be a
fundamental difference here that we have
to understand
this was the problem of a logic for or a
language for
isomorphic invariant p raised by chandra
another thing is that all problems of
interest as i already argued are
isomorphic invariant even kcnf
ksat and these sort of things and
they don't depend on on automorphisms if
you flip
two variables and that doesn't change
the structure of the formula it stays
this viable
another thing is that we want to look at
choice because
essentially having a linear order is
like having a choice you can always
choose the least element in the order
you want to think of it as a
computational resource in the same way
that
we think of random bits or quantum bits
as a computational resource and the
question is
how much of these resources is actually
needed for
for efficient computation and the last
thing is that there is a program here
that
i want to highlight and and that was the
whole point of this talk
so before i get to the program i need to
say what is fixed point logic with
counting and why do we need counting so
one thing is that
fixed point logic cannot do
basic arithmetic with the cardinality of
the structure for example
it cannot even tell whether the
structure has an even number of elements
this was
recognized early on by himmermann
himself and he said okay let's throw in
one quantification that allows us to
count
in particular he said let's use a
counting quantifiers of this type where
you say there are at least i elements
x that's at the side psi but now
i is a variable that ranges over some
special number domain
which we allow which we assume is given
in the input
and we allow some arithmetic on this
number domain the
whole point is that this number domain
and the other domain the domain of
actual structures are only connected
through these quantifiers
so there is no way to order the elements
in the in this
given instructor by the order that you
have in this
arithmetic because there is no way to
connect them one with the other you
don't have a
don't have a bijection between them
so let me give an example of how you do
fixed point logic with counting you can
do quite sophisticated things this is a
basic one first
so let's count walks in graphs so
suppose you're given a graph on some
vertices
this is an adjacency matrix you can
think of it as a zero one matrix with
indices the vertices of your graph now
how do we say that there is a walk of
length 2 well that's the squaring of the
matrix
so or rather we want to count how many
walks of like 2 we have
so we sum over all w's or intermediate
points and then we take the product
one thing to notice that is that this is
isomorphic invariant if you permit to
w's
then because the matrix uh also permutes
then you're getting
you're getting the same count now once
once you can do paths of length two you
can do paths of
uh any power of two by iteration
and this is what you do with the fixed
point iterator
but where here i'm counting exactly i
write saying there are at least
high and there are not i plus one
so this is quite a powerful way to to
compute things
for example so here is the list of
things that you can do with
fixed point logic with counting you can
do connectivity
queries this you can already do in fixed
point logic you can do two sat
you can decide the satisfiability of a
two cnn formula
you can decide whether a cnn formula has
abundant with a resolution refutation
for some fixed width
you can design horns that you can
execute unit close propagation which is
essentially the same as horizontal
ability
so these are things you can already do
with fixed point
now once you are counting you can start
doing things like perfect matching or y
parted graphs
and you can do matrix not singularity
over finite fields you can do algebraic
things you can also do determinants over
the rational numbers you can solve
linear systems of equations
you can do linear programming you can do
perfect matchings or general graphs
you can even do the ellipsoid method so
it becomes a very
very wide fragment of polynomial time
for which we actually
know how to prove lower bounds so it can
do all this but at the same time we can
show that it cannot do certain other
things
but the focus of this talk is not on
lower bounds i would be happy to give
another talk
on lower bounds and adam foot for say
games and all that goes into them which
is beautiful results
but today i want to focus on upper
bounds so let me tell you how to do the
terminals for example
how do you do the terminals in a way
that preserves the isomorphism
of of the adjacency or of the matrix so
you have a matrix of rational numbers
and let's say they are zero one entries
just for simplicity they can be just
any rational numbers think of an
adjacency matrix
now the determinant of this matrix you
can
you can express it by the usual formula
and if you look at it it happens to be
isomorphic invariant
that doesn't mean you can compute it in
polynomial time in isomorphic invariant
way
because that's an exponential big sum so
the question is whether you can compute
determinants of rational numbers
in fpc and here computing you what you
want is to compute the value
as a binary relation that as a relation
that encodes the binary bits
the bits of the input so one warning is
that gaussian elimination as a
this is a fantastic algorithm that is
used all the time
it's not good for us it's not the
the choice the choosing a pivot is not
something we can do because when we
choose a pivot we're breaking symmetries
so gaussian elimination is not available
but the nice thing
is that there are alternatives so level
real method for example
if you are in characteristic zero you
can express the determinant
of i mean the characteristic polynomial
of the matrix
with a recurrence uh the coefficients of
the
characteristic polynomial can be
expressed as a recurrence that depends
only on the trace of the powers of the
matrices
but the powers of the matrices were
already said how to do in fpc
so it's available in fpc and the rest is
just the
recurrence of from a basic arithmetic
that you are allowed to do
in the fixed point logic
what about the trace well what the trace
is just the sum of the diagonal elements
and the diagonal is of course definable
because it's just the selection
of the entries of the matrix with equal
indices
that's exactly the sigma so you select
the
the
the diagonal you add them up you add the
whole layer
that's expressible in fpc therefore you
can express the coefficients
and once you have the coefficients you
plug zero you get to the terminal of a
um a bit out of time so no i don't have
time to discuss linear programming
it's a beautiful algorithm for doing
linear programming due to
anderson the water and home it's based
on refining the ellipsoid method
i don't have time to discuss this
so it's a beautiful beautiful album so
instead of that let me
finish with a couple of slides of some
directions of feature work that i think
could be done here
so there's a program here that one can
put forward which is
that okay we have this very big fragment
of polynomial time computation
it can do many things it cannot certain
things it cannot do
like solving systems of linear equations
over finite fields
so that it can but it can do for
characteristic zero it can do for many
other things
so it's a big fragment and now the
program is to prove the predictions that
complexity theory conjectures do
but do that prove it unconditionally and
by the predictions i mean that i don't
want i don't pretend to prove the
complexity theoretic conjecture itself
but whatever is predicted by this
conjecture
so here is an example so i put it in
abstract terms that you can complete you
can put it
in concrete terms you need games
conjecture one let's put it in abstract
terms
conjecture x says that problem y is hard
okay that's exactly what the unique
of squares gameplay whatever you will
have in mind you want to show that this
family of algorithms cannot refute the
conjecture x
and you want to do it unconditionally
because this is predicted by the
conjecture
so the way to do it is you show that the
algorithms in this family z
are definable in fpc and then by
reductions in the end you can show
that uh you can show that in fact
these algorithms cannot solve this thing
and therefore
and you did that unconditionally now for
the unique games conjecture there is
some initial work uh
by jamie tucker faults uh this is a very
recent paper that is very interesting
and
it does it doesn't solve the unique
conjecture
for the algorithms of fpc
for but it makes some good progress for
hardness of approximation
like max 3sat and maxx or site and all
that we did it with another war a couple
of years ago
and finally one last example that
connects to the
next stock is the following so
again within this program suppose you
want to prove lower bounds for a proof
system
x what do you need to do
well one thing you can do is show that
the proof search algorithm for this
restricted complexity proof search
algorithm for this
is expressible in fpc and in fact this
is one way
and joanna cremiak and her talk earlier
in this series
talked about this approach to proving
lower balance and this is precisely the
topic that benedict pablo is going to
tell us about in the next
talk so why would that be enough well
because
your proof so you want to say suppose
that a certain formula is
easy for system x well then
this fpc formula would be able to find
the proof because you're sure that the
proof search is too awkward in fpc
but on the other hand you know that some
formulas are hard
to distinguish in fpc from
unsatisfiable formulas are hard to
distinguish from for once
so it could not have had a small proof
in the first place
so this way of proving lower bounds has
actually been put to work
and this is what benedict is going to
tell us about
so i'll stop here and i think i'm a bit
over time so thank you for your
attention
thank you albert for an amazing talk
um questions please
i have a question go ahead or comment
so uh avitabul and vianu and me we
introduce a kind of an intermediate
model of relational machine
that in some sense it really tries more
to
say how do we compute those relations
and without having to know logic so to
speak so you you basically says okay
suppose we have right programs
that that can use relational algebra
and then we are able to show kind of
tight connections to this to
to the logic yeah i'm aware of your work
in fact it was very excited at one place
but i was running out of time so i
decided to reflect to to go back to plot
and for relational algebra but i'm aware
of your model
and uh yeah it's definitely in fact in
the abstract i even
talked about relational machines and
this thing this is your your
terminology relational machine yeah
basically you have a store
of relations that you are allowed to
manipulate
through basically a turing machine that
has instructions that say
what to do on the tape and what to do
with the relations
right right it's a beautiful model it's
useful
has not been very influential for some
reason
there's a question by valentine
is there a non-uniform version of fmt
that can talk about circuits yes
absolutely this is an excellent question
and something i wanted to talk about too
so i i focused on on the uniform model
because that's how
most of descriptive complexity in the
early times was developed
but the non-uniform model makes perfect
sense
and all the lower bounds in fact are for
the non-uniform model
so why is that so first of all what is
the model
the model is that now we have you can
imagine you have a fixed point formula
or
even first order formula it doesn't
matter because you can look at
them as unrolled and you have one
different formula for each input like
input size so
for graphs of size 25 you have a formula
for graphs of size 26 you have another
formula
and the only condition you put on these
formulas is that they should all be
in size bounded by some polynomial for
example or some exponential
or some sub-exponential function and now
the lower bounds for proof com for
descriptive complexity they work in the
non-uniform setting
because the way they are proved is by
showing that you have two graphs
that look very similar and yet they are
indistinguishable by formulas of certain
size
or certain certain width to be more
precise
and that depends only on the size of the
graphs i mean you don't need to have
infinitely many
graphs to play around you have only two
graphs of a certain size
and you play the error and fight for a
second to show that they are
indistinguishable
and therefore you can construct
infinite families of such graphs one for
every input size and therefore you get
your lower bounds
now the thing is that the lower bound
you get is for circuits that satisfy
a symmetry condition they are not
arbitrary boolean circuits they are
symmetric boolean circuits and this is
the topic of my talk
in a few weeks ago i gave in the seminar
and anushawar also gave a talk on this
concept of symmetric circuits
so we get lower bounds for non-uniform
symmetric circuits
exponential lower boundary
thank you any other questions so so i
had one question
uh if you let me go back one slide
or the last slide where you showed the
the uh yeah so i i'm trying to
understand
what you're saying here so you're saying
that um
fpc is this restricted uh version it
doesn't completely characterize p
right it characterizes some large
fragment of p and
if you show that proof search for a
proof system
x is easy by showing that
proof searches in sfpc then that would
in turn imply that
the the size lower bound on proof system
x basically basically that's what you're
saying
yes okay what's
a bit confusing is how can proof search
be easy if they are all hard
right they are all np hard more or less
well here because i'm thinking of proof
search for proof systems
like uh bonded with resolution there
that is easy i mean the only thing is
that depends on the parameter
so you have for with w you get time
n to the w but that's okay because we
have lower bounds than the exponential
so if proof search in n to the w can be
done in fpc with w variables that's the
terminology that is being used so if you
can do it with w variables then a lower
bound for w variables will give you a
lower bound for
for with w so all these things actually
match
very well i had one more question at the
very beginning of the talk
you mentioned that the correspondence
between relations and first order logic
and you said that the the relational
algebra that you showed there is
variable free
now this would be true for finite
relations right is it also true for
yeah yeah so i forgot to say this is
finite relationship okay
yeah that's it's important yeah
it's final model theory it's final
relationship all right okay yeah i mean
good well in fact this very relation
this holds for infinite ones as well but
um
for infinite domains but not everything
goes through
so for example in this joule this is
quite interesting um so least fixed
point logic and positively fixed point
logic so this is
we don't allow negations on the fixed
point operators so these two things
in finite structures they happen to be
equivalent they are closed
so we say that this fixed point is
closed under complementation
but for infinite instructors this is not
so so this is a theorem
of by immerman by the way it's a theorem
of finite structures
of final volume
thank you very much that was a very
enlightening talk thank you albert